this morning 48 Hours has more details
about the murder of a Florida woman in
her own home a case that went unsolved
for decades Linda Slayton was killed in
1981 and her two young Sons spent years
living in fear of an unknown man they
called the monster nearly 40 years after
the crime DNA LED police to their
mother's killer it turns out he was
someone so close to the family that one
son had his photo hanging in his home
Jim Axelrod has the 48 Hours
investigation
1981 was the day these men say their
childhood ended Jeff Slayton and his
younger brother Tim had been awakened by
police and told their mother had been
murdered I'd have died that not trying
to save my mom but I didn't hear nothing
it's so hard to live with that Lakeland
Florida police hustled the boys outside
but Tim still in his pajamas caught a
glimpse of his mother's body she had
been raped and strangled
I saw the whole crime scene right then
and there it's a 12 year old kid
investigators collected a rape kit and a
palm print lifted from the windowsill
where the killer had entered her
apartment
cops questioned a slew of suspects but
no one was charged the boys moved in
with their grandparents soon they were
back in school they started living life
again I guess you know going back to
football
Linda Slayton was a divorced mom and
Coach Joe Mills had stepped in to help
he's my friend giving me routes to games
rise to practice and I looked up to this
guy
before long the case went cold and
stayed that way for nearly four decades
I'll probably take my last breath and I
know who murdered my mom
but advances in DNA technology led to
renewed hope and that carefully stored
rape kit revealed an unlikely suspect
Coach Joe
now those car rights to practice looked
a lot different Pete asked us how the
case was going he wouldn't ask questions
about he just what is any new news or
any new leads and I was like no nothing
you know he's talking to a 12 year old
boy and trying to keep tabs on a murder
investigation through the son of the
murdered woman no yes
when he knows exactly who did it he's a
coal holder monster that's for sure
Jim Axelrod joins us now to talk about
this Jim good morning so what do police
believe happened here well the police
thought that Coach Joe who you just saw
had dropped the kid off and then circled
back several hours later when Mom and
the boys were out of the apartment broke
in through a bedroom window hid in the
closet mom comes home with the boys says
good night comes in her room and out the
attacker comes and did he know did they
was there something going on between the
two and what is the motive here there
was not the the real story that you're
going to see tomorrow night is a story
of police having this guy talking to him
the day after the murder did they
suspect him at Angel that's the thing
Gail he was they talked to him on the
phone they didn't take any fingerprints
they didn't do a face-to-face interview
so he wasn't considered a suspect even
though he was within sight of the
apartment as he admitted to the cops 24
hours before but this as as much of this
is a story of a hideous and heinous
crime it's also a story about how
cutting-edge technology can reach back
into time nearly four decades and solve
a case that had become among the coldest
that the Lakeland Florida Police
Department had ever dealt with but I
feel for those boys to lead when you
said he had a picture of him in his room
the killer in his room okay all those
memories now change this this idea think
about this for a second this kid who's
12 has a picture on his wall of his team
which which by the way assumes even more
meaning in the wake of this crime he's
looking for somewhere to just sort of
spend some time so it's his football and
who's over his shoulder and the picture
of the team picture the guy who killed
his mother wouldn't find out for decades
good on the Lakeland police department
for keeping that rape kit all those
years that's right you'd be getting in
good condition hopefully that family
will find some justice uh Jim mcelrod
thank you very much fascinating story
you can see Jim's report the Betrayal of
Linda Slayton on 48 hours tomorrow night
at 10 9 Central right here on CBS and on
Paramount us